Nicholas's here you're very welcome when
you came into the sky studio two hours
ago you were met with a rapturous
welcome and I was given to think if Owen
Farrell had walked in he would have got
less noise fewer handclaps what is it
about you know but I think that would
have got made four on four is amazing I
play an amazing person as well thing
they did all the team did well it was
just yeah somebody had to win somebody
had to lose
is it possible to sum up what your life
has been like since Yokohama on the 2nd
and November a bit dizzy you must be
pretty dizzy yeah something I'm not used
to like going to restaurant is not the
same anymore but I love it because I
know why people excited and happy you
know we we did something big I don't
think we understand it yet but that's
the beauty of sport when you did the
tool around the principal cities of
South Africa including Port Elizabeth
that sorry but you grew up and hundreds
of thousands of people joined yeah it's
beautiful to see it was amazing kids
crying people crying because you know
not everybody gets to see this in their
lifetime and I'm so glad I was part of
that because the people helped us a lot
they send us videos we saw videos from
moles people watching it in shops or
wherever they could and they open it up
so people homeless people will also
watch the real of places homeless people
so we had the energy of the whole
country behind us we could feel it you
talk about people not being able to see
it it was when you were growing up that
you weren't always happy to watch for
the be you know you have a TV at some
point what did it feel to you lifting
that World Cup I can't I can't explain
it in words but like the the pure joy
that I had have been with all my
teammates
beside me and next to me because I know
what Jeany will be mean and we all have
our different journeys but the one we
had together as a team because we just
took two years or three years before
we're losing 58 mil and nobody was
coming to the stadiums and the way
things were turn around by coach Rasmus
and his coaching staff monitor yourself
and medical team was just amazing
and a lot has been made of the fact that
you are the first black South African
captain to lift this is that important
to you or or is it irrelevant
it is important of course it's important
to for every black kid to know that they
can do this this is possible and but
just being captain was huge for me I
mean being a springbok was enough for me
I mean if it gets taken away and I still
be able to be a springbok
that's enough words it's huge and but
now every single kid from any background
or from any I don't know any struggles
in their lives
now they can look up to to me or some of
my teammates and say I can do it because
he's done before see I want you to give
some personal advice to my ten year old
son when he turns out to play on Sunday
in Andover and tell him why it matters
why rugby works for young people as a
school for life and why it's if not the
greatest sport at teaching people the
aptitudes that getting through life then
one of the greatest why does it make
young people what they are I think I
learned a lot about myself other than my
childhood is just to rugby when I was
younger ready through everything that I
was going to discipline respect the way
we took the ref compared to two other
sport you know I too have to respect God
is in charge discipline I - because hard
as I can and then accountability making
other people relying and you knowing
that you know the only one it's I think
it's important thing that you live in -
obviously and how you treat and respect
other people it and I learned all of
that - i've been obviously for my
parents at home as well but you can take
all that you learn about the into life
in general as well you know and it's
it's important for I think in sports are
quite important those are the things you
learn from who you play individual sport
I mean you gotta be disciplined as well
but
team environments are mates and to keep
your humble because once you step out of
line and you have honesty in the team
and the teammates will tell you getting
too big for the game you mentioned your
family they're your father and travel
abroad for the first time to watch you
play in Japan
how is this journey been for your family
I mean it's obviously been extraordinary
for you yes it's been tough they get
people coming to interview them without
asking come with it I was taking video
so but I think they've enjoyed some of
it somewhere they don't really enjoy but
I think it's been good for us I'm
looking forward now to doing something
for my dad I'm buying my house back at
home P you know he still stays in the
house I grew up in with all the
struggles I'm trying to keep it the same
and not change if you know so much room
somewhere else because one day if I
decide to do something I want people to
see and nothing like this is all an act
and whatever I want them to see where I
come from I want to keep it as it is but
for my family it's changed for me and my
brother and sister my wife and kids is
this has changed radically but your
parents must be so proud of you yeah my
dad is very product that's why I took
him there because every parent dreams of
doing nice things for their child and he
didn't have the means to do that and I
said I think I should do it for him
because I know I would have loved to do
it for me and to have him deal with his
grandchildren he was so happy and one of
my proudest moment because that's the
second time he's watching me live the
first one was my first game is this
something you probably don't get a
chance to talk about very often but I
want to ask you very briefly about it
it's your Christian face yeah
a lot yeah it's one you share with lots
of rugby player national rugby players
he doesn't mean to you as a player
that's everything for me that's why some
people really you're not showing emotion
after one because I know it wasn't it
wasn't me I mean God gave me through
everything and the returns are very
nervous and I know where to find my
strength as much training it's the quad
not everything you can get no I need
that specific thing to get me up to get
me core me to know that don't finish a
conversation you are the commercial
break what a pleasure thanks for coming
in let's just say thank you appreciate
it